merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
journaliste vous avez été journaliste
puis médiateur de conflits armés vous
venez de sortir ce livre négocié avec le
diable la médiation dans les conflits
armés vous dites vouloir élaborer une
sorte de boussole morale dans un monde
en pleine recomposition le sujet qui
nous préoccupe aujourd'hui qui préoccupe
le monde c'est l'Ukraine on a encore
loin de la négociation on est plutôt là
dans une fuite en avant exactement on
est dans l'escalade vous venez de le
montrer et c'est extraordinairement
inquiétant le chantage aux armes
nucléaires peut-être une extension de la
guerre de manière géographique sur
d'autres terrains on peut penser à la
Géorgie ou ailleurs à la Moldavie donc
tout ça est très très inquiétant la
question qui se pose c'est je croise
Hélène ce qu'il a dit un jour il faudra
bien négocier ce jour là malheureusement
n'est pas encore venu il est le sang va
continuer à couler ceci dit sur des
sujets ponctuels et bien il y a eu déjà
un certain nombre d'accords qui sont
intervenus sur dernier mois et je
pensais important c'est important en
particulier pour l'Afrique puisque une
famine sera tout est évité puisque
l'accord sur l'exportation des céréales
et des fertilisants
ukrainiens et russes cet accord du fait
sera devra devrait être conduit parce
qu'il a une durée limitée de 120 jours
donc il faudra bien renégocier avec la
Russie si c'est possible donc c'est un
premier élément la deuxième chose vous
avez parlé du nucléaire et là aussi il y
a l'arme nucléaire mais aussi le
nucléaire civil et notamment ce qui se
passe à zapporica il y a eu un certain
nombre de d'inspecteurs de la IEA qui
ont pu se rendre sur place là aussi
c'est le fait d'une négociation d'une
médiation et il faut s'enlever les citer
parce que finalement on joue quand même
avec des choses extraordinairement
dangereuses et puis troisièmement je
pense que ça va continuer c'est les
échanges de prisonniers on a vu que les
Ukrainiens ont fait énormément de
prisonniers donc je pense que les
échanges des prisonniers dans une
logique presque transactionnelle vont se
poursuivre donc tout ça on touche pas au
cœur du problème on est j'en suis bien
conscient mais au moins ça va satisfaire
disons ça va limiter les souffrances
pour les personnes concernées ça veut
dire qu'il y a un dialogue quand qui se
poursuit entre les ukrainiens et les
Russes même si comme vous le disiez on
ne touche pas encore au cœur du problème
mais on a bien vu laisser la Turquie et
les Nations Unies qui ont réussi à
négocier alors on se fait je me fais
aucune illusion c'est-à-dire que c'est
des accords transactionnels c'est-à-dire
que ça satisfait les deux parties mais
au moins elles ont le mérite d'exister
et si effectivement une des milliers de
vie sont épargnés par exemple en Afrique
et bien tout ça de gagner ce rapport de
force et ce discours hier même ce matin
très dur de Poutine
ça
ça peut comment dire faire monter les
enchères en vue d'une médiation ou pas
en tout cas on est clairement dans un
processus d'escalade je pense qu'après
cette après ce qui a été dit par par le
président Poutine et bien les
occidentaux vont aussi devoir réfléchir
comment face à cette à ce nouveau palier
qui a atteint dans la confrontation
comment vont-ils réagir et ça je trouve
ça terriblement évidemment inquiétant
parce que ils seront bien obligés de le
faire on a vu ces dernières semaines
de la part de Poutine comme disent les
Ukrainiens
je crois que vous avez parlé en
introduction d'une fuite en avant c'est
exactement ça il y a une dimension
presque de quitte ou double qui est
terriblement inquiétante donc il faut à
la fois j'imagine dans la perspective
des gouvernements qu'il réponde et de
l'autre côté laisser malgré tout une
porte ouverte j'ai pas l'habitude de
citer le pape mais le Pape a dit
effectivement et là je suis d'accord
avec lui il faut dialoguer y compris à
les agresseurs même quand ça pue ici ça
pue mais il faut le faire mais comment
cerner Poutine il dit tout et son
contraire finalement le président russe
il ne parlait il n'est pas une guerre
d'annexion une guerre de conquête la
visiblement ça l'est puisque il y aura
ses référendums qui
ensuite permettront d'annexer de manière
illégale les territoires conquis par
l'armée russe à la Russie on a le
sentiment que la négociation avec lui
paraît impossible
il est la fille vous avez entièrement
raison la fille a la fiction des
référendums ce qui ne va pas changer
grand chose sauf du point de vue enfin
disons de la machine de propagande ce
qui je pense que malheureusement
tragiquement le champ de bataille va
décider dans les prochains mois ce qui
va se passer avec aussi une incertitude
pour les pays européens comment les
sociétés européennes vont-elles réagir
avec avec une vie beaucoup plus chère
avec un gaz beaucoup plus cher tout ça
je pense que Poutine est en train de
tester finalement la solidarité
européenne or les États-Unis et l'Europe
sont les principaux bailleurs de fonds
de l'Ukraine et évidemment les
principaux ceux qui le rapport des armes
donc là aussi il y a il y a regardé non
seulement la confrontation directe entre
la Russie et l'Ukraine mais aussi
comment les occidentaux vont se
positionner et justement vous dites dans
le livre que les divisions mines de plus
en plus le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
on est en pleine assemblée générale à
New York ça sert encore quelque chose
c'est déclaration des présidents à la
tribune ou alors ça sert seulement à
alimenter un dialogue de sourd écoutez
il y a la part de la rhétorique à la
part de la propagande il y a la part du
discours ceci dit malgré tout il faut
quand même une instinct une enceinte où
les gens puissent discuter alors c'est
terriblement insatisfaisant l'important
encore une fois c'est que un certain
moment il va falloir revenir à une table
de négociation est-ce que ça sera dans
les prochaines semaines à entendre
Poutine je ne pense pas malgré tout un
jour il faudra bien je croisais le ski
le dit et de ce point de vue là il a
raison mais le président de l'esqui n'a
pas non plus intérêt à négocier
maintenant alors qu'il reprend le dessus
sur le terrain militaire nous sommes
entièrement d'accord c'est à dire que
effectivement
le temps de la médiation le temps de la
négociation n'est pas encore venu vous
dites également que la vie
internationale est faite de compromis
insatisfaisant et de pragmatisme la paix
est un messie business ça veut dire que
la paix parfaite n'existe pas et on en a
encore loin en Ukraine on vient de le
voir naturellement disons ça serait
merveilleux si on vivait dans un tel
monde
combien de de victimes sont frustrés
quand il y a des accords de paix
évidemment elles ont tout perdu elles
ont perdu les leurs et qu'est-ce qu'on
leur offre si peu si peu mais il y a des
médiations qui ont réussi dans
l'histoire il y a plein de médiations il
y a écouté prenez simplement les années
90 les accords de paix en Bosnie on peut
dire que c'est fragile c'est
terriblement insatisfaisant mais le sang
a arrêté de couler donc ça c'est quand
même progrès les accords de paix sur le
Cambodge sur le côté malin sur le
Salvador etc etc etc
j'insiste aussi sur le fait que c'est
pas parce qu'on signe aussi un bout de
papier il est toujours observé certains
ne le sont pas ou certains ne changent
simplement la configuration du conflit
vous prenez les accords sur le Mali qui
ont des Accords d'Alger de 2015 et bien
ils ont changé la dynamique du conflit
ils n'ont rien résolu sur le fond et au
contraire la violence n'a fait que
s'étendre et à contrario les accords de
1000 ce que par exemple ont abouti à la
guerre en Ukraine puisque finalement
rien n'avait été réglé exactement merci
Pierre Azon accepter notre invitation je
rappelle le titre de votre ouvrage qui
vient de sortir négocier avec le diable
la médiation dans les conflits d'armée
on voit que c'est très difficile et
qu'on en a encore très loin en tout cas